country visiting bookstores libraries
festivals and authors here are some of
the people on places we visited Brooke
masters author of spoiling for a fight
the rise of Eliot Spitzer miss masters
who is Eliot Spitzer Eliot Spitzer is
the Attorney General of the state of New
York and he's running for governor and
what makes him interesting is that he's
done things that attorneys general
generally don't do which is enforce
environmental rules go after Wall Street
take on insurance firms he does stuff
that you expect your federal government
to be doing not your state attorney
general how involved was Spitzer in the
writing of this book did you have access
to him during he was actually really
great about granting me access without
conditions I he did about a dozen
interviews let most of his staff talk to
me and then didn't ask you know to proof
the book right it's my book not his and
he in fact I think disagrees with parts
of it now why do you think a lot of what
he's known for is this taking on
financial industries why do you think he
set his sights on these particular
industries I think two reasons one is
that he really believes the role of
government is to protect the little guy
from the big company and so he wherever
he sees a an imbalance of power it goes
after government he used his government
to sort of redress that balance and at
the time he was sort of at the height of
his powers in New York was 2001-2002
which is when the tech bubble crashed
and lots and lots of Americans were
losing their life savings in the crash
of an ron and and the destruction of
WorldCom and you know everybody who
everybody who had put all their money in
Wall Street that they needed for
retirement and for their kids college
education was really angry and Spitzer
saw that there was sort of a need and an
interest in going after those folks you
placed him in a historical context in
the book and one of the past politicians
that you compare him to is Theodore
Roosevelt can you elaborate on that so
if some people think it's hubris for
Spitzer to compare himself to Roosevelt
because obviously Teddy Roosevelt is one
of the great icons of America but
Spitzer would say that Teddy Roosevelt
was the the son of rich people who made
their money and believed in capitalism
but also understood
at left unchecked big business can be
bad I mean if it can just destroy the
environment it can take advantage of
people it can exploit workers and that
Teddy Roosevelt understood that if you
if you wanted to keep America great you
had to sort of let business do its thing
but also keep it under control and he
saw his role in tackling Wall Street
very much in that vein that you know
Wall Street's a great thing it's an
engine of New York State it's an engine
of the country but left left to itself
without anybody serving as policemen it
can get a little out of control as his
view what would you say is the biggest
obstacle to his political career he's
from New York I mean frankly he's a
liberal Jewish guy from New York he
wants to be governor I think he can
easily do that he's leading by
tremendous percentages in all the polls
but if he wants to move on and sort of
seek national office you know liberal
Jewish guys from New York are not the
ideal presidential candidate and so he's
gonna have to prove that what he does in
New York is applicable to the rest of
the country and you know something that
other people in completely different
parts of America are interested in what
do you want a reader to take away from
this book I think I want them to take
away that this is a guy who really
believes I mean he's got a vision for
how America ought to work and that you
know he's very effective at putting
forward that vision and that making
other people go along with it
and I don't so much want them to decide
whether he's good or bad but I want them
to understand that this is a guy with a
lot of passion it's caught the books
called spoiling for a fight because he
really is a guy ready to do battle you
know kind of like st. George on the
dragon he's off to slay his dragons
visit challenging writing a book about a
present-day politician as opposed to
someone in the past who you might not
have to hear criticism from afterwards
it was I mean I I knew that whatever I
did was gonna come under criticism from
somebody because Spitzer is not only a
present-day politician he's a highly
controversial present-day politician and
so everyone was going to either think I
had you know gotten too friendly to more
I was too harsh or actually what's ended
up interestingly enough being the main
Chris in the book is that I'm too flat
that I'm you know that I'm very
even-handed and I let people make up
their own mind I personally think that's
the book I set out to write because I
really think readers should decide what
they
think for themselves but it is
interesting and what's particularly
challenging is his career is not over
the guys 47 he's you know he's got big
ambitions he's probably gonna be
governor of New York and then who knows
from there so it's a little hard to
guess what the end of the book is I mean
it's got an end but I almost feel like
there ought to be another edition what
is your background
I'm a Washington Post reporter I've been
working for the washing toast for 17
years covering lots of different things
my real love is courts and and the
criminal justice system and how because
I think how our courts deal with the
great controversies of the days show
America in action it's one of the places
like a legislature where you really see
what our culture is about Brooke masters
thank you
thanks for having me for more
information about the book TV busts
visit our website